this is Startalk welcome to Startalk
radio Bill Nye the Science Guy here
guest hosting for my beloved colleague
Neil deGrasse Tyson
I'm here with Eugene Mirman and Mike
Massimino whom we call mass because it's
it's a complicated name it's hard to
pronounce Massimino yes I'm glad I'm
lucky I got it right you can't tell but
I literally just tried and failed and I
just give up give up as bad as mass that
aside gentlemen I I want to point out
this is cosmic queries edition star talk
radio so we take your questions out
there
in the in a land of so yes Meharry
cosmos which includes the earth young
social media so earth and up and down
wait a minute so trying to write here we
go oh here we go
Sebastian mahalo hey from Romania he's
got a nickname tonight probably I'm
saying it wrong but you know what with
confidence anyway from Romania he asks
which was the most important
breakthrough in the history of
electronics I think the ability to
generate electricity in the first place
was a big breakthrough stead of just
getting it if I made just getting it
from chemical processes is he looking
for transistors I don't know no no it's
also for a starter in an automobile or
is looking for fuel cells fuel cell or
basically electricity and then
electricity is the big breakthrough but
then there's been some some very very
interesting accomplished I just wish you
were like tape recorder at the light
bulb yeah well for me my radio of course
cuz we're on radio how the story for me
is Michael Faraday so Michael Faraday is
sticking the magnet in a coil of wire
and he induces a magnetic field to move
a compass at the other end of the table
during a lecture the Christmas lectures
in London he he woman comes up to him
and says but mr. Faraday of what use is
it and he says madam of what use is a
newborn babe in other words he knew this
electricity had some fantastic
properties but he didn't know what it
was
I eat it yeah newborn babes not that use
for you so long time ago
it was a different choice a different
time yeah but already man but in the
course of human history it wasn't that
long ago no yeah a little bit ago yes ah
yes the poor Hogan's Heroes I believe
older reference lost on momiji
reservation was absent World War two it
probably was better than this was before
World War two its own foreshadow World
War two let's take another question on
cosmic queries star talk radio gay Jess
Nadal no fairness yeah
Jessica dalla asks what's new on the
subject of high temperature or even room
temperature superconductors are we
getting any closer to grasping how it
works and will this knowledge in
conjunction with 3d printing create a
new industrial age sounds like he's
making a prediction of his own doesn't
he's like am i right
what do you think he's a sage yeah we'll
see maybe she's a sage 3d printing is
fabulous and what's this what's the
state of superconductors into I don't
know that though we have superconductors
that work at sort of liquid helium
temperatures mm-hmm everybody wants kind
of hold yeah yeah forty-four Kelvin yes
yeah corn Elvin sounds cold it is cold
even colder than like Canada yeah so
it's like super Oh Canada yeah uh but
wouldn't it be good if they worked with
liquid nitrogen wouldn't they were good
if they worked with with frozen water
yes but it's a long way off as far as I
know but that doesn't mean it can't be
done what I would do were I king of the
flurries is a vest again in these
nanotubes in the getting carbon atoms to
arrange themselves in these
extraordinary tubes where they have very
very low electrical resistance all right
but to do it the 3d printing thing is
yes we ready amazement in carbon tubes
blah Oh could we ever do that is that a
thing in the future is very reasonable
to me but right not a carbon tube
printer but have you guys ever 3d
printed I've never done yeah they have
me and you know they're affordable now
sort of can get over eight balls really
yeah we hope that in in how much are
like of meeting a few thousand dollars
or less than two thousand dollars
oh wow then you can make your own salt
shakers I can't wait to go home and make
you guys again plastic swords to bear we
can't people can't see the scars
radio but Eugene's I was just like yeah
I was like these ready to get out of
here and go buy a 3d printer yeah but
you know they use them we have them in
the labs in the shops at Kauai for
example in there and the students learn
how to use them and they know incredible
things before the next generation of
kids will be like why aren't you 3d
printing like that why are you going to
a store to buy something like right yes
so it's additive machining if you've not
thought about it generally when you
shape something you remove material
generally mm-hmm but this is a process
by which you add motility I don't get
out that's right it's quite a different
idea and you can make shapes that are
literally were literally impossible to
make Wow heretofore is quite a time to
be alive it's exciting it's great all
right and a Sapien asks what is the most
revolutionary engineering challenge that
humanity must overcome in the next 20 to
30 years well I'd say it's climate
change so how are you going to do that
I'd say it's going to be engineering the
whole earth I mean thinking of the whole
earth as a system and getting people to
work together to can manage that system
which would be engineering engineers use
science to do what solve problems and
make things roses party with that's
right things create parties make things
and solve problems yeah
so basically climate change that's what
I would say where is the greatest we get
we have a lot of people in the world and
a lot more coming and things like water
and healthcare and yeah transportation
all those things that are going to face
us engineers need to solve yes all right
that's a very reasonable and correct
answer oh it's correct yeah okay
deplorable perception that is probably
not someone's real name I am guessing
that is that form of Ceuta unless their
parents were diabolical and also unless
they have what is perception yeah thank
you yeah
so here's his question I like that I'm
like it's a guy how will we solve the
looming question of energy storage
that's a great question I am all for the
liquid metal batteries these are
batteries that have magnesium floating
on a layer of molten salt essentially
table salt and
the bottom is a layer of antimony Orin
Timoney mm-hmm
which is the one that's atomic number 51
I believe next to ten on the periodic
table and so you pop or this is all
correct where's our fact checker so you
pump in energy and it gets hot and it's
molten and that works how long is a
battery in it how long does the storage
well as my understanding as long as it's
hot it's storing electricity so you'd
put these things in the basement of
every building in the basement of every
New York skyscraper at every school and
library you make an you produce
electricity with sunlight and so and
wind during the day you store it
underground you're ready for it all
night and we revolutionize society and
whoever goes into this business mm-hmm
gets dare I say it rich ah it's an
opportunity for somebody if you could if
we could find ways to efficiently store
electricity better batteries yeah we
would change the world and make a much
higher quality of life for everybody so
we have to move on gentlemen I include
you Eugene thank you and we'll be back
after this check us out at
www.netapp.com/snapcreator
welcome back to star talk radio Bill Nye
the Science Guy here guest hosting yet
again the time of my life with Eugene
Mirman and astronaut Mike Massimino call
a mass we're here he's an engineer Mike
a mass is an engineer eugene you are a
comedian Camille I'm an engineer but
well I got it when I was in eighth grade
I got a negative eight on a math
assignment just to give you a sense of
my knowledge of math and science so you
do understand the number line and
usually you're saying in numbers and I
appreciate that that is an absurd thing
to get very unusual where do you Karen
say when that happened I think they were
disappointed in a teacher that would
stick to logic they defended you yeah
well I think they wrote him a letter
saying he breeds a disgusting math did
they go and say he deserves at least a
minus for it was like you should give
him a zero physical here this Starace
gentlemen here we go this is the cosmic
queries edition yeah of star talk radio
and so where we take your questions and
eat them from your Facebook's or
Twitter's all that the electric the
electric computer questions that the
kids send in what do you got there
here we go you Julian Rosso asks what is
magnetism how two magnets work I know
there's those things that stick to your
fridge but the force is all around us
and protects us from solar bursts I like
that that's at the end of the questions
a question yeah that's true he's in the
band insane clown posse never it was
really reference I guys know that a song
about magnets it was really the early
stuff now they're just completely over
produced but that said yeah magnetism is
generally thought of as a current a flow
of electrons which have an electric
field which induces a magnetic field
through a term coined by my personal
hero Michael Faraday all one word
electromagnetism no mass you're an
engineer yeah you took a lot of physics
I did but I'm just amazed to hear this
is Bill Nye the Science Guy explain
magnetism or just I can't just we're
going with the physics when we have a
per mile
well we have a permanent school we think
of a virtual current that is to say it's
as though there's a current flowing in
the magnetic material yes iron cobalt
nickel yeah or some of these fabulous
rare earths but in the earth which was
which the questioner referred to to
which the question referred in the earth
we have somehow a spinning giant mass of
by our standards very large mass of
molten iron which carries a lot of
electrons which are in motion which
induce a current which creates a
magnetic fields very important for our
survival it keeps our atmosphere in
place it we're really a whole our
atmosphere is kept here by magnets
partially so yes if we did not have our
magnetic field we would it affected some
theories if you look at Mars which does
not have a magnetic field that why did
Earth survive mm-hmm and as far as we
know at least on the surface there's
nothing so vyas that's Liam all mars's
core with a hot giant ball of iron
that's spun what it's been naturally if
it was there
well Maj is finding it about the same
solutions we get in a magnetic field it
might have had a different destiny could
it be a toward an atmosphere be created
if a magnetic field was added to it or
might be be able to be captured possibly
okay so it's generally believed that
since Mars was - was smaller than the
earth it radiated more heat into space
cooled off solidified and any molten
motion of metal inside it came to a
standstill and then the solar wind
little particles streaming off the Sun
stripped the Martian atmosphere away and
while we all sit here mm-hmm just a
couple weeks ago I went to Cape
Canaveral for the launch of the maven
mission cool Mars atmospheric volatile
evolution hmm spacecraft it's a tortured
acronym but they're going to assess the
electron it is a Kulak maven it's pretty
good it's pretty good they're going to
assess the atmosphere learn more about
the atmosphere of Mars and what happened
there why Mars is different from the
earth and that will I guarantee you
questioner that will tell us more about
us and our dare I say it place in space
so what I'm getting from this is
theoretically we could create an
atmosphere on another planet using a
great deal of iron and a bunch of
various and scuba tanks scuba days
physically scuba tanks a handful of
whales alright but a magnetic field is
very very important it's the first field
then we do the thing from search for
Spock where we bioengineer a planet but
okay never you've got a crazy plan there
that is great you gene but it I have to
say I don't know what are you talking
about but it sounds good it's not that
crazy of you I'm looking at Bill Nye the
Science Guy just have forgotten of for
confirmation honest but it sounds good
all right when you start getting into
the Star Trek movies yeah there's gonna
be some inconsistencies terraforming a
planet is just not that easy but it's
not I'm not saying it's easy you know
saying here's a few ways we could do it
don't underestimate the magnetic field
exactly well set awesome
alright so Lorenzo al fondo Caston on
Gonzales asks I would like to know more
about magnet ours can humanity one day
create such a strong magnet and how much
would such a magnet advance technology
do you I don't know what magnet ours are
do you know what a magnet or no it
sounds like bill doesn't know forget it
well it just sounds like a very powerful
magnet a musical instrument that's how
uses magnetism oh yeah if I guess if
one's big enough you could you could
influence a lot of people it's like talk
about a theremin he's talking about some
huge strong magnet yeah obviously he
don't if he is by the way we in the
skeptic community yeah our trouble
deeply by people who wear magnets
believing that it's going to influence
their health
really there's no lot even on the wrist
this there's no one of your magnet
eugene yes
yeah I know oh my god wouldn't I be
embarrassed about wearing a bunch of
magnets there's no evidence that's no
evidence at all that we can see yeah no
evidence of all at all that magnetism
affects your health it's just it's just
so little just next time you get an MRI
yeah magnetic resonance image just
notice how much magnetism it takes just
just to get a few positrons to move
around just a little bit yeah takes an
another wearing it as a Mack
it hat yeah it's just not gonna do yeah
all right well uh so that's good to know
okay so Jason Hyatt has a question the
earth has a magnetic field that protects
it from space radiation is there any
reason why a magnetic field could not be
used on a spacecraft either for the
whole ship or as an emergency shelter an
MRI scanner produces a very strong
magnetic field why not a magnetic field
generator all on MRI to protect
astronauts that is what a coincidentally
happy question right yeah if you had a
strong enough magnet yeah you could pull
it off but our problem so far as
generating enormous magnetic fields
takes a lot of energy need really how
much a lot like as much as a like a like
a coffee maker that's like supercharged
be a little more than that so like a
boat like a giant boat a cruise ship
like a diesel engine on a pretty long
like a tugboat diesel engine okay but
that's more than you would have on your
average are you ever see and giant and
we're yeah you don't want any big stuff
like that you don't want to fly with a
truck into space but just imagine that
defeats the purpose just imagine if we
had solar panels big enough and some
superconducting situation in the icy
blackness of space and you could create
a magnetic field strong enough that's
actually a science fictional kind of
cool engineering question but I think
when least right now early in the 21st
century we humans can't crank that out
we can't make such a thing but who knows
what the few that but if we started
doing more space exploration we would
potentially come up with that technology
down the line it seems like something if
you had that much power yeah seems you
sense power every but there's other we
do other things for for space radiation
like uh suits like like space suits
waters are pretty good insulator EXO
really yeah and shielding you know the
spell or and and we try to understand
how much you you take we always wear a
dosimeter when you go into space
oh really measure how much are you
taking are you exposed to like when you
was it's a pretty good dose uh it also
depends it also depends on where you are
spacewalks you get more than when you're
inside the spaceship at a higher
altitude by where we were at Hubble as
opposed to where the space station Wow
just a few hundred tens of kilometers
make a big difference right and late
time you're going to be there and if
there's solar flares when you're up
there so it's a bunch of factors but
it's nothing it if you fly in space for
over a year or so like some people have
a combined over a year stay they have to
track it and make sure you're okay
that's when you start getting a little
bit curious but we have astronauts who
have flown Scott Kelly's going to be up
for a whole year as the plan he's
already been up over six months in his
life and seriously himself in water yes
yeah he's going to he he's going to stay
out of the Sun but when you say what are
you jacket the spacecraft well for
example water can yet so if you have a
water bag like on the space station you
want to get some extra extra shielding
if you would have to line the outside of
your spaceship with with water for
examples you line the outside or is
there a your side means no there is no
layer of water I'm saying if you were
trying to if you were worried about a
solar flare for example your spaceship
and you had water bags that would help
you that you wish you add so you just so
know you're taking your anyway yeah so
use your use it as a shielding let's
give you frank irradiated water it's not
that irradiated it's fine you know I
yeah no it's fine it's great that's no
problem it's great there's nothing
better than irradiated water from space
yeah back is probably a market for it
this problem somebody who really wants
three full bar in Brooklyn that sells it
all foods is actually a good question
Eugene that's not bad oh that's that's a
back home wait a minute hold that
thought you guys we'll be back shortly
at star talk radio
welcome back to star talk radio Bill Nye
the Science Guy here hosting this week
for Neil deGrasse Tyson who's on radio
Stickle sabbatical I suppose now unlike
many of you I'm here with Mike Massimino
who flew in space and we call Mass yep
that's that's what they call we have in
general we I'm an engineer but you're
also an astronaut and I'm here in New
York City on loan at Columbia I like
that you're honorable
I'm on loan really like the idea of
borrowing astronaut there's no late fees
as far as I can tell yeah and the other
voice you hear of course is Eugene
Mirman our providing color commentary
yes here on the most visual medium of
star talk radio now this is as you may
know if you're just joining us this is
another cosmic queries edition of star
talk radio where we embrace your
questions yeah you the listeners viewers
wait you the listeners i podcaster
absorbers who use your social media to
provide us with your cosmic queries
Eugene here we go ow
Wayne Shaw wants to know if one were to
warp space to travel a vast distance
with people existing in the space that
is being warped between takeoff and
destination and destination notice
anything unusual
well they don't in the movies the people
in between the inbetweeners like
someone's hanging out say some people on
some planet so so we're assuming there's
someone else out there that's gonna be
armed by the idea that of course since
you know you went through a stunt space
warp and of course you can see what I
understand that these things are big fun
when you're trying to create a
science-fiction television show where
you really don't have time to have
people not speaking English and you got
to get up and down from a planet and
travel around various quadrants in the
galaxies or galaxies but these things
are more theoretical than they are and
so we will see how people do is they go
between extraordinary destinations
through unproven theoretical spaces in
space where they notice I think this
person suspects them
might have seen something yeah would be
notice anything unusual
right right this person is like I saw
something weird something unusual all
right hamburger special looked a little
bit different today than it did the
other day is it says someone warped
speed through the diner
well like the government's oh come on
he's going on here I think yeah so Josh
Corona asks in the game a very good
science name no no that uh no Corona is
a good science it's a solid Nia okay in
the game portal they have a gun that can
create what is essentially a wormhole in
a wall with the ability to shoot two
holes one an entrance and the other and
exit ie the floor ceiling rate is this
possible in the laws of physics oh sure
you'll be fine just go get the gun and
shoot it this way and then very quickly
shoot it the other way before the other
hole closes so there haha two holes it
good to know oh he has another question
a bowl well I need to stop playing more
video games apparently I don't know what
this kid is talking about it with this I
got jaw okay so he also asked if you had
to guess which would could be first
achieved first light speed travel or
teleportation so teleportations like
they did on Star Trek together like
wobbly make sure you know you're
somewhere else but haven't scientists
already teleported light isn't that a
thing that somebody did it in a lab just
everybody now first of all as far as we
know missing out on some portal game
with guys shooting holes of worms or
whatever it is where have I been
yeah well you better chase I know I'm on
the government payroll missed out on a
lot of things bill I like some guy
teleporter no no because that'd be best
person did since I start with the first
one you right now we don't know of any
way to send something that has mass
beyond up to the speed of light right
right now there may be a whole nother
physics yet to be discovered perhaps
this questioner will be the person that
makes the discovery yeah he's got to
stop playing the game portal yeah get
yet and go back to physics class and
then a second thing teleportation where
you turn mass into pure and not me no I
was gonna talk about mine and be an
example then you go on acid we know you
can turn the past on you know into pure
energy
beam him down to what we generally refer
to as the planet and then he's
reconstituted that would be converting
mass into energy back in a mass could be
done but consider equals mc-squared
it's a tremendous amount of energy to
convert even a small amount of mass into
something well so it may happen so maybe
just a piece of corn still start with
something a person yeah or should we
start with just one element well I think
if you can get anything a carbon atom
would be pretty extraordinary even
hydrogen but in that sense you're saying
teleportation is potentially
theoretically possible before it just
shooting from the hip yeah but going
faster than light right now I take
either one how far you gonna teleport
there she likes speed travel you jeah
and get you places quickly yes I'm not
sure about to tell how far we go we go
to college are we going to Mars with
this I think we got a feeling I got a
feeling we needed Lightspeed first you
might set up Austin but if you teleport
somewhere Boston we can get there anyway
yeah so I'm gonna teleport you to Mars
you're gonna get this up there's no
place to go right B no one else's we're
on stair exactly I think we need like
speed travel first check the place out
well he's not asking what we need first
he's asking what's more realistic in the
annual but I don't know I'm not a Swami
sounds like teleportation he thinks
barely so still says yeah I take either
one I'd rather Lightspeed try let's go
fast
let's enjoy it alright let's punch it
let's enjoy that let's enjoy the ride uh
so where were we
this is Startalk cosmic queries yeah we
encourage you all to check us out on WWE
star talk radio dotnet if you've got
SoundCloud YouTube iTunes Pinterest
Instagram tumblr I say party on start
with Facebook and just go wild and of
course when you're listening to Startalk
radio stay tuned
welcome back to start talk radio Bill
Nye the Science Guy here hosting this
week your cosmic queries your questions
from the cosmos and I am here with an
astronaut an engineer and so far
gentlemen Mike Massimino still early OMS
and of course everybody's favorite
Eugene Mirman
Eugene there you have questions on
pieces of paper queries yes the cosmos
uh I say query let's do it
David terrazas asks what does a rocket
push against in space to gain momentum
or navigate Oh mass that's your that's
what we do in space and it's a great
question because if you know you don't
have any gravity so when you navigate
your spaceship you need to point it in
different directions there's a couple
ways to do it
Hubble Space Telescope for example has
no fuel on board so there's one rocket
kind of leave that is a turn it turns
which is it with little kids up no
there's no one there to push it is
nobody said no fueled you didn't say no
little kids free so he's soldier stuff
you didn't say you know a lot it's
reaction you know lion it's what we
could it's reactions reaction wheels
reaction wheel spin me a big control
moment gyros which is kind of the same
thing on the on the space station these
things spins you know they spin up and
they creates a reaction and that
reaction creates an opposite reaction
right spin them in there in a certain or
in a certain direction and you'll get a
reaction in the other direction and the
thing will point where you are they sort
of gyroscopes exactly that's pending
that's one way the other way we did on
the space shuttle and on other space
ships do this in fact the space station
has this on the Russian and what we call
thrusters what is it it's gas
could be nitrogen could be something
else yeah but just a guess they're going
to comes just around like that if you
can't hear them in space can't hear it
is just that you hear it you hear it
inside of the spaceship shaking it is
yes sorry you these leases rustlers were
released there again it'll cause area it
will cause an action mm-hmm which is the
release of a gas and a little little
rocket and you'll have a reaction the
other way so on the space shuttle we had
large and small thrusters different
different varieties all over the
spaceship mainly in the front at the
nose and in the back that you would fire
to get the correct orient
it's just like you have the steering
wheels on a car and yes exactly you can
steer all you want you're not going to
go anywhere your control surfaces do not
work because there's no air when you're
coming down on the shuttle even what
does it look like an airplane yeah it
will not be active until you pick up
atmosphere so the way you turned and
pointed and steered that space shuttle
yeah was with these little little
thrusters that would fire yeah the one
you're looking at gravity but let me ask
exactly let me back up on this question
back up is there anything to push
against and the whole idea when you
watch the rocket leave the ground it
gives it gives you the impression that
the flames and gases are pushing against
the earth but that's not really what's
going on you're throwing gas hot gas out
the back of the rocket so fast that the
reaction is the rocket goes off in the
other direction stand on a skateboard
and throw a bowling ball to your best
friend or and maybe your enemy and you
will find that the skateboard goes off
in the other direction rice works
whether or not you're on the earth or in
space so basically the rocket fuel is
just the biggest bowling ball weak
increase and goes fast more or less all
right we don't throw it at our enemies
huh okay Melissa Kay asks if you had a
charge enough space fear of water
floating in the space station could a
fish swim in it oh how cool yes I we've
done this with with swedish fish the
candies but my parents will live no but
theoretically I think that would work
water is uh I mean you could have a tank
of water and have a fish float in there
I would don't see why we wouldn't be
able to do that and water itself is it
works just on surface tension so it
doesn't splatter so if you were very
creative you could get a glob of water
and try to get a fish they wouldn't even
need a tank no but have to be really
careful as soon as it hits something
it'll it'll splatter you don't want to
fish nosing nuzzling his or her way out
of the sphere of water right but I'm
pretty sure there have been experiments
with with fish in space and so yes this
is definitely possible because they'd
have some way to be a nice Christmas
gift you know you have met fabulous
zero-g going around we have to get pets
flown and this would be a good way so
right now we've had fish as as
experiments this would be like a nice
what animals have been
in space I mean with with astronauts not
just like monkeys that can't make it
back or something right or the dog Laika
yeah uh it's been there's been spiders
in space there have been some rodents in
the house that were used for for
experiments ok so again it's all
experiments we let me ask you this
physics question Mike masse yes the fish
are going to breathe air dissolved in
the water when you have a glob of water
in space does the air bubble its way out
effervesce or does it will it depends it
can stay in there if nothing's acting on
it it will it will stay in there in fact
this is a problem with our drink bags
bill when we when we spacewalk because
you don't want air in your drink bag no
no liner in your drink so what we do is
when you fill your drink bag when you
fill a bag of water you drink back for
your spacewalk it's see-through you can
see that there might be air pockets we
rotate the bed we spin it I'm sitting
right now to get the bucket over your
head that's right you spin it to try to
get the air to one to one location and
you suck it out so you can't get air
pockets and you want those air pockets
we'll be right back and start decorating
welcome back to star talk radio Bill Nye
the Science Guy here guest hosting as we
take your cosmic queries on Startalk
this week and we have come to the last
segment of this show which means the
lightning round my friends where we take
your questions from you the cosmos and
put them on the air for your let's say
electromagnetic enlightenment I'm here
with Mike Mussina I'm gonna do it I'm
here with Mike Massimino calm mass and
and and eugene meyer man Merliah feel
like you got a name like nah yeah that's
all I you know with a name like IO wits
anytime you've anything else to do it
you guys I appreciate your in spoil Bill
Nye that's very that's very simple
enough but when I hear should suffer
gentlemen it's the lightning round
look anyway I got a press of machinery
ready these must be fast answers ass
like lightning
Marco Horvat from Bakersfield he has
people that see UFOs claim to see
strange lights why on earth would a
spaceship of an advanced civilization
need lights on the outside of their ship
to see where they're going like
headlights I don't know I
yes I think we need more evidence that
these were actually UFO that yeah right
yeah yes there is I think they're seeing
airplanes yeah yeah there's a weather
saying so that Elliot sir Mike Johnson
from Barstow California asks how close
would an alien civilization have to be
to discover earth using the same
technology we have here oh that is a
fabulous question now just to talk more
about me when I took astronomy from Carl
Sagan this is before yeah did you put it
back no I was just in the room I was
just one guy so we had must have been a
fun class that was cool so we had this
image of this organism eating little
organisms ingesting them and spitting
him as astronomy yeah and it turned out
to be an image of a swimming pool taken
from a satellite so you have to get
extraordinarily close to really a
determine whether or not something is
alive or or you'll get fooled right but
I think they need to be
close to us right Co meters yeah we have
we just left the solar system now right
with the voyagers yeah they couldn't be
much further than acts I guess so
hopefully they're just on the other end
but yeah all right here's a question for
Matthew Brown is there a theoretical
limit to the size of a Sun I keep seeing
graphics comparing our Sun to larger and
larger solar Giants just how big can
they get when would you get to be a few
hundred solar of Sun diameters you
become a black hole really yeah you
become a star that has so much gravity
light doesn't escape Michael is in
senses would you describe it as over a
million whales uh uh yeah
big whale that wouldn't be an accurate
what he's little well accurate way to
describe well you've heard about a big
wheel well but over a million a factor
of I guess 10 to the 19th or something
yeah like the whale that's hanging from
Neil's Museum exactly those of you have
been the New York City to America Museum
of Natural History
so son that was too big would just
become a black hole laughs yeah well
that's what it apparently it does they
do
oh great no well that's up now I know
how to make a black hole thanks look out
world
Jason Paisley asks when the Sun
gradually expands will it's an expanding
mass push earth farther out of orbit
before Earth becomes consumed no won't
push it out it will absorb it yes the
earth would stay about in its same orbit
and then the Sun will expand to cook
it's not going to be a good day either
way the Sun is an earth eater yes and we
don't want to experiment with that
either to find out okay david Loza asks
what if neuron receptors in the human
body were to react at the speed of light
well they react at the speed of
electromagnetism between atoms
pretty slick it's like would we change
that so in other words uh I get it this
would be instead of acting I said if I
don't if we instead of having my apology
instead of having the neurons go at
chemical speeds they below at speed
light speed well I guess would be what's
that a factor of about a million maybe
Oh ten ten to the seventh might be ten
million
okay really fast what would be the
advantage could we run faster yeah what
can we get is we can do everything
faster really quickly million times
faster it seems to me yeah but then it
has to be hooked up and there has to be
you have to address capacitance issues
and oh you know we are made of a liquid
chemical brain yeah talk to a joy thing
be cured style you feel we're given to
me to take a moment and relax I just did
take a second and relax
you alright here's a question coffee
breaks would be like instantaneous okay
Jacob seymour asks is the shape of a
black hole a sphere with high density in
the middle pulling space in toward the
center or is it a flat disc with a point
of high density pulling it down in the
middle like a funnel I believe it
depends and this is where Neil deGrasse
Tyson would be born into this Neil quest
I'm not an astrophysicist but I can
answer it incorrectly though I guess
it's an or take a shot well just
whenever you have any asymmetry this
gravity's pulling all this stuff
together from extraordinary places in
space they're not going to come in
perfectly evenly so in general they will
start spinning like the ice skater when
he pulls her arms in and so you'll often
get a disc that is measurable
perceivable detectable so the answer I
believe is it depends and Neil can get
on here and and light me up so that's a
pun I see because if they like I'll get
it
hahaha that's brilliant well you guys
thank you all for listening to cosmic
queries here on Startalk radio I have
been joined by mass Mike Massimino
astronaut who flew in space and of
course Eugene Mirman tunas turn us up
loud on Startalk radio podcast it blast
it
this is Startalk